I told you there's a travel advisory from Mexico.
Yeah,
I know freak me out,
but they're only killing each other,
you know what I'm saying?
But for now,
and occasionally they go dark,
but I look Mexican so I'm like,
Ooh,
maybe the key first or they kidnapped me.
I'm like a Saks low.
Ooh,
Ooh.
I,
there's like miss the shrub.
We will talk about the,
Oh,
we love Mexico.
We will have Mexican cans but they're too short.
So we brought you in to the VA sex slave.
They're going to impregnate to all these beautiful women.
Ah,
with your perfect DNA.
I'm just like a stud horse.
Just slang and Derek out there just getting pussy and a slingshot.
You guys think I'm being tortured but it's awesome.
We have this new thing,
it's a mixture of zinc,
magnesium,
steroids and you just loads of just building up in your balls.
But I got to make videos like being mad at America and Trump and shit.
But you guys can tell him happiest fuck down Jack from all the steroids and
girls like pulling on you.
You're like,
stop,
stop.
Please not now to say this wall,
it's fucked up and it's the reason why I'm stuck at Camp please.
Their client at yet,
and you're just,
you're the tip of your Dick Peaks
on these,
hopefully fucking seal team six
boys,
please,
please and stick around for awhile.